Shakira cancels her scheduled  performances at the upcoming Latin  Grammys and American Music Awards the  singer took to Twitter Tuesday to let  her fans know she won't be at the award  shows simply writing quote due to  personal matters I won't be able to  travel to Las Vegas and LA to attend the  Latin Grammys or the AMAs this year  those are very powerful reasons  earlier this year the mother of two  teamed up with fellow Colombian star  Carlos Vives for their duet la bicicleta  she lamented quote I will be  accompanying Carlos Vives in spirit at  the Latin Grammys celebrating this  incredible year that we've shared  together a rep for Shakira had no  additional comment about her current  circumstances our hearts go out to her  you